[Music]  it's nice day for a drive huh beautiful  day the sky  large caliber weapons I love getting out  of the office ooh  Jana needs stitches lucky for me I'll  still need them tomorrow next week the  president is adding drug cartels to the  list of terrorist organizations you want  to see this thing through I'm gonna have  to get dirty you know help us start a  war with those everyone  I need Blackhawks strike teams attack  drones or is it coop massacre you have a  kid  not your brother I don't want to kill  the pool guy  now that we got the cartels at each  other's gross secret won't keep  [Music]  good luck  boom badda Bing love there's only been  the side of the border  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]